bom pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
cartas e os trabalhos e que busquem é
também da noite treino eu já esqueci
como é que se joga mesmo bar é nada
muito alto
ai ai já começou já consultamos no
quarto é que o burnley brunet vocês
poderão não tem vídeo prejulgar em
alguns riffs mas não conseguiu
ai eu venha entrar na fila sal mas eu
não deixei ela prometeu muito empenho
ae é não olhar seu palhaço o meu deus
naquela boca pegar sofrida
ai ai eu tenho acredito que estou de
volta e volta pode malha lançou andré em
seu quintal conforme já não saí já não
sei que meu cérebro está muito alto
refuto visão fogo quase porque isto
porque meu ainda cantou i'll culpa de
lavar as capinas sair do gol
não não só com outra vez agora vamos com
calma muita calma até meia-noite idoso
estava calma e não abriu a porta a
ninguém que eu não quero aqui no quarto
ae ouvi um barulho aqui ó tá frio que
está fazendo o que está fazendo aqui
taxa estava na janela não está normal e
não para batata na porta da unha 2012
ninguém é punido quem eu deixei luz a
minha volta neste momento muito mesmo
está tudo mais não é também a porta não
está tudo bem não
em trecho pilan pilhas fim mas conseguiu
aguentar dados não são de que o do
mônica rondon pai do meu pai do céu em
cima do peito com nunes a esse seguro a
itália janelas aib estudo maior embora
ainda mais a sério jovem steel pelo fogo
aí eu pergunto eu tô aqui alguém não
pega quem está vindo da casa se eu tava
janela é pedra tentar o ensaio deixe o
seu tapa janela e alguém pegou no chão
mesmo tempo já não saísse um dos
movimentos que estão aqui não dá assim a
turbinar o cérebro não não não não
conseguisse aquilo que eu falei com o
dono do imóvel é da pane uma pizza pizza
e ganhei o meu como é que eu conseguir o
meu funk não como é que conseguiu esta
proeza não sair mas vamos lá está aqui
eu tô aqui está muito alto nível está
muito alto
cheguei agora no 4 nada aconteceu
mentira para obtê las a um do comércio
sempre na forca em filas não quer saber
só tem uns a porta janela ventilação tá
tudo bem eu nem consigo ouvir a minha
voz como evitá aqui não é único e evitou
a moça vai não acumule um campeão
o zezé sabe subir o túnel e decide falar
com o zé do luxo
aí ele pegou
ae aí está outra vez a luz lá fora'
pagou tão longe
davis o deputado baixo da cama janela
mentira na janela da arquitecta mais
detento ok eu vou tentar apanhar mais
uma vez por sua pasta que mais ganharam
tranquila pilha o funk corrupção sinal é
um sinal do demônio ainda não vacinaram
os filhos vai vai não apenas em ai ai eu
entro aqui dentro o bicho papão já fiz
gosta eu abri uma vítima são não
e os encontrou debaixo da cama tem com
essa certeza eu levantar aqui perto
muito perto sentir um cheiro é mesmo pra
queimada na porta da minha filha sabe
deus é pior que o preocupa uma vez desta
vez consegui passar esta noite né
só precisa estar mesmo tempo a pilha e o
moço mosca a boca eu achei isso vai
contra mesmo para tirar o sovaco luxo
isso vai resultar em nada para o shitake
josé da cunha sério já não dá jorge eu
já não consigo saber estudo mole eu acho
que sob o yahoo condução é no caju
trabalha
peraí óó kurtulus saia quem namora três
da manhã ok eu tenho muita pilha
o que quer dizer que o twitter vai
porque são três da manhã e saio aqui o
bicho o haxixe meu filho luz na porta
quero conseguir a liberdade vocês viram
eu quase que estava em cima de mim mas
eu já tava para o foco entretanto é
normal no nam nam e espanha têm dentro
como é que eu posso tão rápido em emoção
por dentro de um armário como eu tenho
um buraco em cima armário novo então vai
pra dentro do hotel foi que eu moro foi
para dentro o gasto uma pinha toda aí o
barulho do bebê
ai ai caramba tac janela isso eu só
tenho uma pilha pra uma hora e meia eu
tenho que aguentar esta copa iphone pra
não ser os irmãos se não tomar em
goiânia ela e andré paiva dentro
aguentar mais que 50 minutos
esconde-esconde espera lá onde atuam
pelos ideólogos lá fora e mostrei nem
foto 25/20 28/30 janela 21 segundos e eu
consegui passar esta noite muita
concentração muita concentração neste
momento filho da ai ai conseguir você
não esquece uma forma as borboletas bom
cobrem as ruas kaká
pessoal vamos ficar porque o espírito e
espero que vocês tenham gostado final
entre conseguir passar esta noite 10 foi
mais difícil é ver dado nesta noite 4
vai ser ainda mais divertido eo isp só
espero que vocês tenham gostado quanto o
aspecto bonito fique bem a próxima anda